France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'Europe nous sommes sur France
24 et Radio France Internationale
bienvenue au coeur du quartier européen
de Bruxelles dans les studios de la
Commission européenne pour un tour
d'horizon de l'actualité en compagnie de
son vice-président il s'agit du Slovaque
ma recette covitch bonjour merci d'être
avec nous alors en fait vous êtes en
charge à la Commission de la prospective
et des relations inter-institutionnelles
ce qui vous oblige à essayer de régler
des différents avec des pays tiers très
proches mais aussi par exemple à tenter
d'assurer notre avenir énergétique on va
parler de toutes ces sujets l'un de a
vraiment marqué les Européens c'est un
accord justement le cadre de Windsor
pour faciliter la circulation des
marchandises au sein du Royaume-Uni en
évitant une toute frontière physique sur
l'Irlande du Nord il a été conclu début
mars par la présidente de la Commission
européenne avec le Premier ministre
britannique conservateurs richiss Unac
après effectivement de longs mois de
tiraillement post-brexit vous êtes ce
négociateur post-brésil est-ce que pour
vous cet accord est bon et applicable
oui cet accord est bon applicable quand
vous avez dit c'est pas facile à réussir
dans ce domaine parce que on a eu à peu
près des ondes de vrais tensions et de
discussion difficile mais je dois dire
avec la nouvelle équipe de Première
ministre de chez sunac todétape
absolument différent je dois dire que
mes relations personnelles avec
le ministre des Affaires étrangers James
Clavel Léo le ministre irlandais
Harris sont magnifiques et je peux dire
la même chose la qualité des relations
entre notre Président nous reçoit un
après-midi
une nouvelle chapitre dans nos relations
vraiment réglé tous ces problèmes qui
étaient parfois tout à fait difficile
pour le peuple d'Irlande du Nord et pour
nous c'était quand vous savez très bien
très important très important de
promouvoir la paix sur l'île
d'Irlande mais aussi en même temps de
protéger la l'intégrité des marchés
unités européen je crois que on aurait
aussi dans tous les domaines maintenant
bien sûr
notre défi c'est la mise en oeuvre de
cet accord d'ailleurs cet accord
il est en position de certains
d'ailleurs conservateurs dans le camp du
Premier ministre mais aussi du petit
parti unioniste d'Irlande du Nord
viscéralement attaché à l'appartenance
de la province britannique au
Royaume-Uni qui bloque les institutions
politiques locales également le niveau
de sécurité a été relevé vous n'êtes
plus du tout inquiet d'un redémarrage
des troubles on a toujours inquiet c'est
pourquoi on a dit très clairement que on
comprend que la partie de
nyoniste à besoin de temps pour
réfléchir pour vraiment évaluer cet
accord je suis absolument convaincu que
on a démontré qu'on a vraiment écoutez
on demande dans le domaine de
d'agriculture dans le domaine de
contrôle douaniers dans le domaine de
mouvement de des personnes de c'est
pourquoi c'est un accord qui est très
politique
cette technique en même temps on parle
de presque de 250 pages de de textes qui
sont vraiment très très techniques mais
je crois que ça nous permet de créer une
condition pour lire l'angle du Nord qui
maintenant l'accès au marché au Niger
européen et en même et en même temps on
marche onique
britannique on m'a déjà dit que
l'intérêt d'investisseur mondiaux je
peux dire et très très élevé je suis sûr
que ça va aider à l'un du Nord avec cet
accord ont aussi à ouvert une nouvelle
chapitre pour cette pour cette
redémarrage économique d'ailleurs les
Britanniques les Anglais même se
demandent si ça ne rouvre pas la
possibilité d'adhérer au programme
scientifique horizons avec des
financements de 80 milliards de livres
stères line
je peux confirmer ça et on va commencer
cette discussion sur notre accord
un accord du futur accord sur la
coopération et la commerce et là bien
sûr il a un chapitre sur la recherche
sur la coopération dans le domaine des
sciences et le royaume britannique sera
bienvenu dans notre programme
Horizon mais bien sûr on doit aussi
discuter sur quelles conditions quels
sont les contribution
financière qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
ensemble je sais que les hommes et les
femmes s'intéressent les universités
britanniques sont extrêmement intéressés
de participer dans ces programmes et
maintenant j'espère qu'on va discuter ça
aussi avec nos amis britanniques vers
tout ça c'est vite possible c'est une
des conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
les prix qui flambent pour les Européens
on a vu des grandes grèves en France
mais aussi en Allemagne en Belgique
est-ce que vous vous inquiétez de cette
grogne sociale
je suis d'accord avec vous que
maintenant c'est pas facile pour le
ménage en Europe c'est tout à fait pas
facile pour les opérateurs économiques
ce sont vraiment les plus élevés pour
l'énergie l'inflation qui est assez
élevée aussi c'est pourquoi on doit
travailler ensemble le paiement pour les
institutions européennes pour
pousser le prix énergétique pour
pour répondre
cette inquiétude à l'inquiétude de nos
citoyens qui ont vraiment travaillé
ensemble pour améliorer le condition de
la vie en Europe alors l'Ukraine on est
au chapitre de l'Ukraine elle a commencé
à recevoir ses premiers chars lourds
livrés par les Occidentaux des chars
britanniques mais aussi Allemands sont
arrivés sur le sol ukrainien d'autres
livraisons sont promises alors que la
Russie agit dans le même temps la menace
de déployer en Biélorussie des armes
nucléaires tactiques et ce que l'Union
en fait assez pour que les Ukrainiens
gagnent bien sûr on peut dire ça c'est
victoire l'Ukrainienne je peux dire que
on a fait tout possible parce que des
premières moments de première journée
nous étions à côté des ukraines je suis
un très bon relation avec le Premier
ministre
quelques jours après que la guerre a
déclenché et simplement c'était
absolument clair que les Uraniens sont
très courageux que sont très des
défendre leur pays que on a vraiment
besoin de les aider jusqu'au maintenant
ce qu'on a fait on a on a consacré
presque
70 milliards d'euros pour pas seulement
soutenir les Ukrainiennes mais aussi
pour soutenir le père européenne qui ont
offrir les abris pour les réfugiés quand
tout ça aux États-Unis que à certains
moments on a plus de 8 millions réfugiés
de l'Ukraine et que c'était vraiment les
citoyens européens qui sont ouvrir les
portes qui sont ouvrent les maisons qui
sont ouvrir les écoles les hôpitaux pour
les Uraniens c'était aussi pour nos amis
américains impressionnant et en même
temps je suis absolument convaincu qu'on
doit continuer de les aider parce que ce
sera on est très très important et on
voit que les ukraines ont besoin de
notre soutien financier notre soutien
politique dans le domaine de des armes
de munitions
la Finlande va réussir son adhésion à
l'OTAN car il n'y a plus de blocage mais
la Suède elle est toujours bloquée par
la Turquie qui veut tradition des
opposants à rehab taillés père douane et
puis il y a aussi le gouvernement
hongrois de Victor Hormann qui a dénoncé
à plusieurs reprises les mensonges
répandus par des responsables de suédois
les supposé mensonges donc sur l'état de
droit en Hongrie est-ce que vous
déplorez ce WTO je crois que c'est tout
à fait très très malheureux parce que
bien sûr les finlandais elle a
souhaitent seront les pays qui vont
contribuer d'une manière très très
importante pour la sécurité de la
défense de l'Europe de pays de l'OTAN je
sais pourquoi
je sais que mes collègues diplomates de
l'OTAN de mes collègues
finlandais
suédois ils sont en négociation
permanente avec l'engrais avec la
théorie parce que je crois que tous les
mots va bénéficier quand le fondant la
souhaite vont devenir le membre officiel
de l'OTAN je rappelle que vous êtes
slovaque effectivement plutôt
social-démocrate la Slovaquie c'est un
pays qui appartient à l'est au fameux
groupe de vie secrète avec la République
tchèque la Pologne et là Hongrie mais là
on gris semble peut-être isolé de ces
trois voisins justement et partenaires à
cause de l'ambivalence du Premier
ministre Victor Hormann proche de
Vladimir Poutine et qui sur la guerre en
Ukraine n'est pas très claire et puis
Orban qui héritait en particulier la
Slovaquie parce qu'il a apporté une
écharpe de supporters de la Hongrie avec
les frontières antérieures au Traité du
Trianon qui incluait la Slovaquie
je crois que après cette
écharpe avec cette
symbolique qui est très très controversé
en Europe et sur un Slovaquie je crois
que c'était une très bonne geste que le
premier ministrelovaqua donnait les
échelles avec aussi la carte de la
Slovaquie après au Premier ministre
hongrois mais bien sûr nous sont en même
région nous sommes les voisins et c'est
pourquoi
on doit travailler d'une manière
diplomatique et politique avec le
Premier ministre hongrois parce que
c'est très très important
notre région qui est sur la frontière
avec le grain qui qui est je crois le
plus affecté par la guerre en Ukraine et
le citoyen on ne démontré comment sont
prêts à soutenir les Ukraine pendant
cette crise
des réfugiés après le déclenchement de
la guerre c'est pourquoi on doit
travailler avec les ingrats passent les
mains pour le soutien pour les graines
aussi pour le soutien pour l'adhésion de
la Suède à l'OTAN mais parce que ce
groupe de vis de grade qui était
d'ailleurs un peu sur des positions
eurosceptiques dans un bras de fer avec
Bruxelles sur beaucoup de sujets
notamment les migrants est-ce qu'il a
encore un sens aujourd'hui vous avez
raison sur par exemple la question de
des droits sur une question de
l'adhésion
Slovaquie la Tchéquie sur un côté la
Pologne à l'autre côté mais
la composition est tout à fait
différente si on discute le soutien pour
pour les graines mais en même temps ce
qui est très important en Europe
les amis les voisins qui sont plus
proches doivent être en position d'avoir
aussi les débats la discussion les plus
ouverts les plus honnêtes les plus
franches et ce qui se passe maintenant à
parmi les pays du chakrate vos
concitoyens slovaquent au dernier
euroboiromètre montre qu'il se méfie à
53% de l'Union européenne comme
d'ailleurs les Français mais c'est bien
supérieur à tous les autres en tout cas
la veille de l'invasion russe en Ukraine
plus de la moitié des Slovaques jugés
que les États-Unis et l'OTAN étaient
responsables de cette guerre et en
septembre il souhaitait que la Russie
gagne plus la moitié pourquoi je crois
que c'est à cause que nous sommes une
nouvelle démocratie et chez nous aussi
cette guerre d'information des
informations très très présentes
vous voulez dire russophile je peux dire
je peux dire aussi la transpiration sur
vraiment la désinformation je dois dire
que aussi c'est le sentiment que c'était
le russe le New soviétique qui a libéré
la Tchécoslovaquie pendant la Deuxième
2e guerre mondiale c'est quelque chose
qui est
utilisé beaucoup par
le média comme ça qui par le site de
l'Internet différents et en même temps
je crois que c'est aussi une combinaison
avec la situation sociale dure on a une
inflation qui est qui est assez élevé
comme je dis le prix d'énergie qui sont
assez élevés tout ça je crois c'est en
résultat qui était reflété dans ces
baromètres mais je sais très bien que
mes concitoyens sont per nature Europe
optimistes je me souviens toujours de
cette euphorie je peux dire après
après cette adhésion à l'euro à Schengen
je suis sûr que on va se revenir dans
cette domaine de positivité soutient
pour le projet européen les pays de
l'Union européenne prévoient le signer
des premiers contrats gaziers conjoint
dans les mois à venir afin d'aider à
remplir les stocks avant le pic de du
prochain hiver vous dirigez c'est ces
achats conjoints de gaz pour l'Union
européenne avec une plateforme qui
démarre en mai à quoi ça sert vous en
attendez quoi parce que c'était une
décision claire de leader européenne de
la des conseils européens parce que
simplement c'est impossible qu'on va
continuer à payer le prix si elle avait
pour le gaz qu'on a payé l'année
dernière
d'être complètement honnête et ouvert
aussi aujourd'hui on doit utiliser d'une
manière beaucoup plus efficace notre
poids politique notre poids économique
notre on est tout simplement être en
position de diminuer le prix des gaz ce
qui s'est passe maintenant et qu'on a
déjà ouvert
notre plateforme pour la registration
pour tous les opérateurs qui utilisent
gaz qui va vendre le gaz pour
travailler ensemble
parce que aussi exprimé leur volonté de
participer dans dans cet efforts et vous
avez raison pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'Union européenne on va
on va organiser c'est l'achat comment le
c'était l'appel à d'offre en mai de
cette année et on va répéter cet
exercice presque chaque mois jusqu'au on
va abouter à obtenir c'est de
d'approvisionnement de gaz pour notre
stockage parce qu'on doit éviter la
situation qu'on aille en août dernier
parce que ça poussait les prix d'une
manière je crois en acceptable pour
quand on est un travail aussi avec le
fournisseur de gaz des stabiliser la
situation parce que c'est très important
pour la pour la compétitivité de notre
économie la solidarité pour payer moins
cher merci Monsieur le vice-président de
la commission ma rosette covid avoir été
notre invité merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis vous restez en notre compagnie
tout de suite à suivre un débat au
Parlement européen à tout de suite juste
après la pause
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre ici au Parlement
européen à Bruxelles pour notre débat
consacré cette semaine à la fin de vie
alors que le président français Emmanuel
Macron devrait recevoir lundi 3 avril
les conclusions des 184 citoyens ayant
participé à la Convention sur la fin de
vie et bien la porte est ouverte à une
possible légalisation d'une aide active
à mourir à l'instar de ce qui se fait
chez certains de nos voisins européens
comme au Pays-Bas en Belgique ou chez
les trek catholiques espagnols dans ce
cas là un médecin aide le patient à
mourir en injectant un produit létal
alors d'autres États membres ont
légalisé autour de moi dépénialiser le
suicide médicalement assisté un médecin
prescrit des substances létales et la
personne les ingère elle-même ou
déclenche la perfusion c'est le cas en
Autriche mais aussi en Italie troisième
option enfin l'équipe médicale en charge
du patient décide de ne pas prendre de
mesures pour prolonger sa vie la mort
pour survenir donc par administration de
médicaments
analgésique ou le débranchement d'un
respirateur en France c'est possible
avec la loi Leonetti en revanche dans 9
pays européens toute aide à mourir reste
totalement interdite c'est le cas en
Bulgarie à Chypre à Malte en Pologne en
Irlande en République tchèque en
Roumanie en Lettonie en Lituanie ce
geste peut vous conduire en effet à la
prison pour de longues années peut-on
choisir la façon dont on meurt et le
moment et bien nous allons poser la
question à nos deux invités sofinet
bonjour vous êtes du groupe prognon vous
êtes hollandaise votre pays les Pays-Bas
a été le premier État membre de l'Union
européenne à légaliser l'euthanasie
c'était en 2001 et Alfred Sand bonjour
vous êtes vous socialiste maltais votre
petit tril donc très catholique et reste
opposé donc effectivement à toute forme
de suicide ou d'euthanasie assistée
d'ailleurs quiconque incite une personne
à se suicider peut aller jusqu'à obtenir
jusqu'à 12 ans de prison comment
d'ailleurs vous expliquer une telle
résistance ce qui se passe c'est que
actuellement
l'euthanasie a été mis sur l'ordre du
jour lors du Jour politique seulement
elle a été dévancée maintenant par une
autre controverse concernant
l'avortement le chef adjoint du Parti
travailliste que de pouvoir il est il a
poussé le sujet du besoin assez
importantes parce que son père a été
effectivement est mort dans des très
grave conditions et il voulait avoir
l'euthanasie et sa position finalement a
été adoptée par le parti et on va
discuter de ça dans les prochains mois
donc le débat est sur la table Sophie ne
tevelte quelles sont les conditions
requises pour demander l'aide active à
mourir dans votre pays c'est très
encadré
oui c'est très encadré et je crois que
il faut d'abord dire que l'euthanasie ça
existe partout il y a juste des pays où
ça a été légalisé où il y a un cadre
légal il y a des pays où ça ça se fait
mais
clandestinement et avec beaucoup de
souffrance et de
d'anxiété d'un qui est notamment pour
les familles pour les familles pour les
médecins
et donc chez nous on a choisi de créer
un cadre légal il faut aussi dire que
les débats n'a jamais cessé parce que on
développe on fait des expériences il y a
peut-être d'autres cas d'autres
catégories donc la réflexion
[Musique]
il faut voir plusieurs médecins experts
etc donc et si on si on
parcourit toute cette procédure à la fin
c'est légal donc il y a vraiment une
procédure très très stricte à suivre
Alfred San l'Union chaîne s'implique
généralement peu dans ces questions de
société où elle a pas peu de compétences
d'ailleurs pour vous parliez de
l'euthanasier de l'avortement certains
états font pourtant pression sur le
Parlement européen pour le pouce pousser
à adopter une position commune est-ce
que vous êtes favorable à cette idée de
d'un corps je pense pas que l'Union
européenne va entrer dans cette question
là c'est pas sa compétence et finalement
il y a tellement de
facteurs culturels par exemple sociaux
qui sont un bonus dans cette histoire
que pour avoir un cadre européen je suis
pas d'accord je suis d'accord pour un
cadre européen dans le contexte de la
santé dans le convergence en ce qui
concerne santé convergence du concerne
même politique de santé mais pas en
question d'avortement pendant des
questions de
d'euthanasie par exemple alors que vous
vous avez écrit une lettre justement à
la Commission européenne sur ce thème
oui soyons clairs on ne parle pas ici
d'une loi commune européenne sur
l'euthanasie on ne parle pas de ça mais
par exemple la commission
subventionne les recherches aux soins
palliatifs et plein d'autres thèmes liés
à la fin de vie donc il y a juste ce
thème ou la Commission ne subventions
pas les recherches dans sur le thème de
l'euthanasie pourquoi ça c'est une choix
politique et ce qui est aussi
intéressant quand nous au Pays-Bas on a
adopté ce cette loi sur l'euthanasie il
y a plus de 20 ans il y a plus de 20 ans
les ce qui était opposés se sont
adressés à la cour à Strasbourg la cour
des droits de l'homme donc eux ils ont
bien reconnu que c'était une question
européenne et
aussi l'avortement c'est pas le thème
d'aujourd'hui mais il y a des des
groupes par exemple très
religieux qui sont farouchement contre
l'avortement et ils ont une initiative
citoyenne européenne contre l'avortement
donc il faut être clair ou bien c'est un
truc strictement national ou bien c'est
un thème on ne parle pas de législation
européenne mais un thème pour débattre
le la liberté de mouvements richesse
échange de de pratique etc ça oui il y a
un exemple qui est qui fait beaucoup
parler en Europe c'est l'exemple belge
l'euthanasie est possible pour des
personnes souffrant de maladies curables
ou en détresse psychologique mais c'est
également ouvert aux mineurs est-ce que
vous vous y êtes favorable non c'est
favorable à l'euthanasie mais il faut le
faire dans un contexte en cadre très
très mais y compris pour des mineurs y
compris pour des personnes en détresse
psychologique
je suis peut-être d'accord
pour devenir non pourquoi parce que
finalement
alors on le fait pour les bébés aussi si
vous voulez
un bébé qui n'est pas n'est pas
chez vous oui oui mais c'est un
programme et il faut il faut pas prendre
ça
ils ont légèrement on en parle beaucoup
c'est un débat extrêmement délicat mais
il y a des des petits bébés qui qui où
il y a aucun espoir de
survivre et qui souffrent énormément par
exemple il y avait un bébé qui avait une
une maladie ou la peau lâchait et donc
il était couvert de sang il souffrait
énormément et dans ce cas là même les
parents
voulait terminer la souffrance parce à
quoi ça sert de faire vivre un tel bébé
pendant encore des semaines où vous
parlez de maladies incurable mais
précisément ce qui choque un peu dans
cette loi belge c'est que les Belges par
exemple viennent d'accorder le droit
d'euthanasie à une jeune femme de 23 ans
en grande détresse psychologique parce
qu'elle avait survécu aux attentats de
Bruxelles 23 ans donc et une mère de
famille de 50 ans
violé mais mère de deux enfants est-ce
que là ça vous paraît pas justement
relever de
finalement de détresse qui peut être un
jour seront surmontés au cours de leur
vie mais bon moi je peux pas juger dans
ce cas spécifique mais c'est pour ça
qu'on a cette procédure
on peut pas prendre une telle décision
avec
du jour au lendemain quand on a consulté
peut-être un seul médecin non et cette
femme elle a souffert pendant des années
elle a elle a je l'ai lu sur le sur le
journal elle a tout fait des thérapies
des cliniques je sais pas quoi et il y a
des gens qui se suivent ici tout seul ça
existe partout et dans la plupart des
cas c'est c'est dramatique il y a une
souffrance et non donc quand quelqu'un a
vraiment décidé de
terminer sa vie moi il faut l'aider je
préfère que ça se ça se fasse dans un
contexte digne et c'est vrai est-ce que
c'est facile non c'est pas facile mais
si il y a une personne qui a vraiment
déterminé quand elle dit quand cette
personne dit qu'il y a tout essayé et
quand l'aimait c'est plusieurs médecins
qui ont qui ont regardé de près ce cas
qui ont et les médecins ils sont là pour
pour
soigner justement mais face à une
détresse psychologique face à une
détresse psychologique on peut se dire
que la médecine est là pour guérir et
pour aider donc en autorisant dans ces
cas-là
l'euthanasie ou le suic assister on
considère que la médecine ne peut rien
pour des gens en grande dépression ou en
cas de détresse psychologique
5 enfants il y a 20 ans qui était encore
dans une condition psychotique assez
importante et la demande d'être en Asie
on l'a fait donc ok ça peut se faire
mais pour moi c'est très important pas
de discuter des questions individuelles
mais des questions de discuter par
exemple les cadres médicaux les quatre
juridiques il faut commencer par ça
c'est pour ça que je suis pas d'accord
que l'Europe s'entremêle parce que ces
quatre juridiques ce cadre médical et
spécifique aux données culturelles
d'idation des sociétés doivent être
compte
dans notre pays en France les opposants
à l'euthanasie on pourra argument qu'on
risquerait d'investir moins dans les
unités de soins palliatifs qui sont là
pour justement rendre aisé la fin de vie
par des médicaments est-ce que c'est le
cas chez vous est-ce qu'on a vu que
l'argent il n'y a pas d'argent magique
et que l'argent se substitue qui avait
compétition entre les deux c'est
toujours bon évidemment cette politique
de prendre les décisions de faire des
choix ça c'est clair mais il s'agit il
faut parler de la fin de vie comme un
comme un paquet où il y a plusieurs
possibilités parfois ce sont des
combinaisons et l'important est toujours
que c'est la personne elle-même qui
décide qui qui choisit et ce qu'on voit
au Pays-Bas par exemple
on a légalisé au fur et à mesure et
élargit un peu le domaine et plus les
gens ont la liberté de choix
moins ils utilisent
la possibilité de faire l'euthanasie
pourquoi parce que ça rassure déjà les
gens de savoir que s'ils veulent ils ont
le choix ils ont cette option vous
prenez c'est la liberté et est-ce qu'il
faut aussi laisser la liberté au corps
médical au Médecin aux infirmiers de de
donner cette possibilité donc
d'accompagner des gens vers l'euthanasie
ou non avec cette clause de conscience
il faut avoir cette clause de conscience
le fait que il y a une certaine
proportion de infirmiers et des médecins
qui sont contre et qui vont rester
compte mais il y a notre portion qui est
proportion qui est pour qui accepte
alors justement il faut là faire le
compromis de laisser les gens qui
veulent pas entrer dans un jeu faire ça
est-ce que l'Union européenne doit
considérer le droit à mourir dans la
dignité comme un droit humain
et officiellement d'ailleurs
moi personnellement je dirais oui mais
je suis très consciente du fait
qu'effectivement c'est un débat très
très délicat je crois que le moment
n'est pas là pour
disons pour dire qu'on va imposer une
loi européenne ça ça n'existait pas
pourtant comme je disais avant les
opposants ce sont adressés quand même à
une cour européenne c'est intéressant
donc c'est une reconnaissance implicite
du fait que c'est une question
européenne mais je vois que comme
l'avortement est comme plein d'autres
questions de santé et de société que tôt
ou tard c'est une question qui se pose
au niveau européen et comme je disais si
la Commission européenne a choisi de
subventionner certains thèmes comme les
soins palliatifs liés à la fin de vie
pourquoi pas l'autre on parle des
recherches et on ne parle pas de loi
européenne l'inscrire dans la Charte des
droits fondamentaux c'est plutôt comme
une valeur européenne
la question on a le droit de vie ça
c'est un droit fondamental le droit à la
vie mais de l'autre côté ça veut dire
qu'on a aussi le choix il y a des
juristes qui l'interprète comme ça mais
je crois que c'est un débat un peu
prématuré je crois qu'il faut qui est
important tant c'est de faire comme un
mal par exemple ou c'est un débat sur la
table c'est sur la table ça c'est très
important et reconnaître que
l'euthanasie ça existe partout oui mais
alors justement sans harmonisation du
droit européen du droit à mourir dans
l'Union européenne est-ce qu'on risque
pas de développer un tourisme morbide
par exemple en France il y a des
Français qui partent en Belgique pour
pour
mourir pourquoi
c'est un risque
mais parce que par exemple c'est
interdit en France donc on va en
Belgique c'est intéressant c'est
remboursé par la Sécurité Sociale
française en partie pour partie moi je
suis pas en compte vous n'êtes pas
contre le fait que on puisse comme ça
choisir le pays pour mourir et pour être
accompagné
mais alors pourquoi ne pas harmoniser à
ce moment-là
c'est pas la même chose c'est pas la
société qui fait ça c'est une personne
qui fait son choix personnel et qui va
où son choix personnel peut être
attendez mais là il y a parce que vous
dites que c'est remboursé par la
Sécurité sociale mais par exemple en
Italie il y a beaucoup d'italien qui se
font en Suisse par exemple mais ce sont
uniquement les gens qui ont les moyens
c'est très très cher donc
ça veut dire que seuls les gens qui ont
de l'argent ont
le droit à la dignité à la fin de vie
tandis que les gens qui n'ont pas les
moyens n'ont pas les choix que la
société nationale doit résoudre pas
l'Europe pardon c'est des questions
et pour conclure à tous les deux est-ce
que vous avez écrit des directives
anticipées spécifiants ce que vous
souhaitez en cas de de maladies graves
de coma ou de dégénérescence rapide
alfreenscent est-ce que vous avez rédigé
les directives
vous allez le faire Sophie
et en plus mais j'ai noté que
effectivement il y a un aspect
transfrontalier là-bas parce que moi je
suis néerlandaise mais j'habite en
Belgique et déjà eu l'expérience dans un
autre contexte avec le don des organes
et tout ça après la mort que je peux
bien signer quelque chose ici mais c'est
pas valable au Pays-Bas et l'inverse je
vous laisse signer quelque chose au
Pays-Bas mais c'est pas valable ici donc
là déjà moi j'aimerais bien que même si
par exemple si je voyage en masse que
même si la la loi maltaise ne prévoit
pas l'euthanasie qu'au moins on respecte
mes droits mon choix et ce seront les
mots de la fin merci à tous les deux
d'avoir très bien participé à ce débat
sur la fin de vie qui va continuer vous
le comprenez et qui en tout cas a bien
un lieu dans cette hémicycle merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis sur nos deux
antennes rester sur France 24 et Public
Sénat
[Musique]